Bonjour!
-Bonjour!
-Ton texte!
-Pfff...
Oh, mais quelle belle robe en soie tu portes!
Attends, c'est même pas de la soie.
-Oh merci, mais tu me fais penser à la route
du même nom! Tu sais, celle par laquelle
la peste est arrivée en Europe dans ma dernière
vidéo, et que Marco Polo a empruntée un
jour! Faisons un épisode là dessus!
-Oh, c'est une bonne idée.
-Allons-y!
Évidemment, on ne parlera pas uniquement
de Marco Polo dans cet épisode, ni même
uniquement de la route de la soie, le titre
était là pour vous attirer.
Déjà, que faut-il pour créer une route
de la soie?
-Une route.
-On y viendra après.
-Et de la soie.
-Aha! La soie est fabriquée depuis plusieurs
millénaires en Chine, et se popularise chez
les romains à partir du Ier siècle avant
J.C.
La soie fait un peu de voyage avant d'arriver
dans l'empire romain: produite sous la dynastie
des Han, ces derniers en offrent aux nomades
Xiongnu pour qu'ils leur foutent la paix.
A leur tour les Xiongnu en troquent avec des
nomades plus à l'ouest, et à force d'échanges
elle parvient aux Parthes qui à leur tour
en vendent aux romains.
Alors Une les romains ne connaissent pas la
Chine, ils l'appellent Seres ou Thinai et
savent pas trop ce que c'est.
Deux ils savent pas comment est produite la
soie.
Et Troie, c'est là.
-J'interromps cette vidéo pour vous dire
que je trouve cet humour pitoyable.
Les romains appellent la soie serica et ça
devient rapidement le tissu à mettre partout,
en coussin, en vêtement...
Comme la soie coûte super cher à importer,
à cause des coûts de production, des dangers
de son transport et des taxes, on essaie même
de l'interdire parce que ça fait trop d'or
qui quitte l'empire juste pour de la soie.
-Ouais mais s'habiller en or, c'est chaud.
-Effectivement, y'en a qui ont essayé, et
ils ont eu des problèmes.
Bref, les romains aiment la soie sans être
capables de la produire, ils pensent qu'elle
vient d'une sorte d'arbre à laine et la production
de soie n'arrive qu'au VIe siècle à Constantinople
et au XIIe en Sicile.
Sans rentrer dans les détails, la soie est
produite à partir des vers à soie, que les
chinois élèvent sur des mûriers.
-Jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient mûrs.
-Non.
-Du coup t'as parlé de la soie, mais t'as
pas encore parlé de route.
-Bien vu, Lulu.
Les chinois de la dynastie Han, dont je parlais
précédemment, continuent de craindre les
nomades Xiongnu, dont je parlais aussi précédemment.
Du coup ils créent les premières missions
diplomatiques vers l'ouest et entrent en contact
avec les Indiens, les Parthes...
Forcément, ces missions sont accompagnées
de marchands, parce que c'est toujours intéressant
si on peut se faire un peu d'argent au passage.
A tel point qu'au bout d'un moment les Han
envoient des ambassades avec juste des marchands,
et aucun ambassadeur.
Je crois que les ambassadeurs sont des MARCHANDS
DE SOIE
Jusqu'au IIe siècle après J.C., les chinois
commercent donc avec l'Occident et des routes
terrestres et maritimes se forment.
Mais toujours grâce à des intermédiaires:
les Parthes, principalement, qui préfèrent
éviter qu'il y ait des liens directs entre
les chinois et les romains parce que POGNON.
Les marchandises échangées sont de l'or,
de la soie, des pierres et métaux précieux,
de l'ivoire, des perles, du corail...
C'est en 166 seulement qu'a lieu la première
ambassade romaine en Chine.
Mais du coup durant l'Antiquité les deux
peuples commercent sans trop savoir qui est
qui.
Les romains pensent que les chinois vivent
2 ou 300 ans, par exemple.
-Bah quoi.
Ils ont bien des hommes à tête de chien
là bas.
-On en reparle après, ok?
A partir du Ve siècle, la route de la soie
n'est plus empruntée que par des marchands
mais aussi par des pèlerins, bouddhistes
principalement, qui contribuent à répandre
le bouddhisme en Chine jusqu'au IXe siècle.
Comme le bouddhisme intéresse beaucoup les
chinois, des pèlerins chinois se rendent
à leur tour en Inde pour consulter les textes
et visiter les lieux où aurait prêché Buddha.
D'autres religions voyagent grâce aux routes
de la soie, comme le nestorianisme, déclaré
hérésie par l’Église mais qui parvient
en Perse, chez les Mongols et en Chine.
Au VIIIe siècle l'Islam arrive en Inde et
s'y implante également.
Mais revenons-en aux marchands!
-Ouais parce qu'on attend encore Marco Polo,
c'est un peu le titre de ta vidéo.
-Il va arriver.
Un jour.
Pour l'instant, nous arrivons au XIe siècle.
L'empire romain n'est plus, mais l'empire
Mongol a pris le relais et permis aux routes
caravanières de se maintenir:
les arabes et les chrétiens continuent de
fréquenter ces routes, pour le commerce principalement,
même si certains chrétiens envoient aussi
des missions religieuses.
Il existe donc toujours des routes terrestres,
mais ce sont surtout les routes maritimes,
entre le golfe Persique et la Chine, qui sont
empruntées à cette époque.
Il faut compter huit mois pour faire le voyage
aller, puis attendre la fin de la mousson
pour repartir, donc le trajet prend largement
plus d'un an.
Les chinois se rendent aussi dans le golfe
Persique, et tout ce petit monde commerce,
se mélange, on découvre la boussole qu'utilisent
les chinois...
Grâce à certains textes, comme la Description
des peuples barbares de Zhao Rukua, on sait
que la Chine importait des bois et résines
aromatiques, des médicaments, drogues et
parfums, des épices, de l'artisanat, de l'ivoire,
de la corne de rhinocéros...
A l'inverse les Occidentaux achetaient de
la soie, porcelaine, du camphre, du sucre,
de la cannelle, de l'encens...
Les liens commerciaux se développent progressivement
avec la création de réglementations et de
commissariats à la marine marchande en Chine,
qui prélèvent des taxes sur certains produits.
En Occident, à partir des croisades les marchands
génois, italiens et vénitiens se remettent
à utiliser les routes terrestres pour rallier
la Terre Sainte et ouvrent des comptoirs en
Méditerranée.
Par exemple, la famille de MARCO POLO, ça
y est on y vient, avait une maison de commerce
à Constantinople.
-A Venise, d'où est originaire...
MARCO POLO les marchands s'organisent en colleganza
pour s'unir face à l'adversité et aux risques
du voyage.
Du coup y'a un mec qui finance le voyage pendant
que les autres font le voyage.
-C'est justement ainsi que commence le voyage
de Maffeo et Nicolo Polo (le papa de Marco)
en 1260: ils partent de Venise et embarquent
vers leur comptoir de Constantinople, où
ils échangent une première fois des marchandises,
puis vers la Crimée où Venise avait aussi
un comptoir.
A partir de là et sans qu'on sache trop pourquoi:
ils continuent, à cheval et sans peur.
-Ils essayent bien de rentrer à Constantinople
à un moment donné, mais la route est coupée
à cause de la guerre.
-Du coup ils continuent, encore.
Ils passent trois ans à Boukhara, en actuel
Ouzbékistan, à l'époque aux mains des Mongols.
De là ils décident sans prétention d'aller
rencontrer le Grand Khan Kubilaï Khan:
à ce moment là on a complètement laissé
de côté l'aspect POGNON du voyage, ils discutent
avec le Khan qui les charge d'un message pour
le Pape: il voudrait que ce dernier lui
envoie cent savants, histoire de pas faire
les choses à moitié, pour lui expliquer
le christianisme.
Ouais, à l'époque y'avait pas wikipédia
donc si tu comprenais pas un truc tu convoquais
cent savants pour qu'on te l'explique.
Les Polo repartent donc vers Acre en 1269
mais apprennent en arrivant que le pape est
mort, donc en attendant le prochain Habeus
Papam ils rentrent à Venise pour retrouver
petit Marco qui a alors 15 ans.
Seulement, Habeus Pas papam tout de suite,
et faute de pape ils reprennent la route en
1271.
Lorsqu'ils repartent, ils décident d'emmener
avec eux le petit Marco qui a alors 17 ans.
La famille Polo repart par Acre, Jérusalem,
Layas, et apprend là-bas qu'enfin le pape
a été élu!
Du coup...
Ils retournent à Acre où ils prennent au
passage deux frères dominicains pour les
emmener chez Kubilaï Khan.
Ça vaut pas cent savants, mais c'est déjà
ça.
-Finalement les frères dominicains ont peur
de la guerre et abandonnent en cours de route.
Pleutres.
Mécréants.
-Ils arrivent donc devant le Khan avec quelques
lettres du pape, un peu d'huile sainte, et
c'est là que Marco prend de l'importance
dans le récit puisque contrairement à son
père et son oncle il reste auprès du Khan,
et effectue plusieurs missions à son service.
De telles missions confiées à un étranger
ne sont pas exceptionnelles: il était courant
chez les empereurs mongols de prendre à leur
service des étrangers comme des tibétains,
turcs, iraniens, arabes, russes...
Marco Polo occupe donc les charges d'inspecteur,
peut-être d'agent de renseignement, et est
envoyé à travers l'Asie pour différentes
missions dont il ne donne pas toujours les
détails.
Pendant trois ans, il est aussi nommé gouverneur
de la région de Yangzhou.
Il parlait le perse, le mongol, et peut-être
le turc et l'arabe.
Seulement les Polo commencent à avoir suffisamment
mouillé leur chemise, et le grand Khan refuse
de les laisser repartir à Venise.
Ils repartent finalement par bateau en 1291
avec des ambassadeurs et entreprennent un
nouveau long voyage vers Sumatra, l'Iran,
les côtes africaines...
Ils débarquent dans le golfe Persique et
rentrent à Venise par la Turquie, prenant
sûrement un nouveau bateau à Constantinople.
On est alors en 1295, plus de vingt ans après
le début du voyage, et à la fin de la partie
intéressante de la vie de Marco.
On sait de lui qu'il reste marchand mais sans
faire partie du conseil de la ville, qu'il
a une femme, trois filles, une maison...
Une petite vie tranquille, quoi.
-Quand même: en 1298 il est détenu en
otage à Gênes et dicte ses mémoires à
son pote de prison, Rustichello de Pise, qui
en fait un best-seller mémorable.
-Effectivement.
Un voyage tel que celui de Marco Polo n'est
pas unique pour l'époque, même s'il était
rarement le fait de marchands mais plutôt
celui de missionnaires.
Par contre, écrire son récit de voyage pour
un marchand, ça c'est badass et jamais vu.
Le Livre des Merveilles, ou Devisement du
Monde, ou Il Milione, ou Il faudrait choisir
un titre à un moment donné et s'y tenir,
est un récit du voyage de Marco Polo qui
décrit les habitants et les particularités
des pays qu'il a traversés.
On y trouve par exemple une description de
la ville d'Hangzhou, qui est la capitale de
la dynastie Song et une importante ville marchande.
Ou encore la ville de Cambaluc, la capitale
d'hiver du Khan, où il décrit du papier-monnaie
qu'on a pas en Europe, c'est dommage.
-C'est encore plus dommage parce que s'il
s'était un peu mieux renseigné sur le papier-monnaie
il se serait rendu compte que ces billets
étaient imprimés, et comme l'invention de
l'imprimerie se fait deux siècles plus tard
en Occident ça aurait pu lui filer une idée
de génie ou un beau mal de crâne.
-Grâce à lui on sait aussi que le Khan disposait
d'un système de poste et de relais très
perfectionné, qui couvrait toutes les grandes
routes de son royaume.
En vrac parce que ce livre est assez riche
on trouve mention de divinités à plusieurs
têtes, de certaines cultures et de comment
elles sont pratiquées...
Mais son livre s'appelle parfois le Livre
des Merveilles, et c'est pas pour rien:
ce style d'ouvrage comporte souvent des récits
de voyage mais aussi des fables, et Marco
ne va pas se priver de raconter beaucoup de
fables.
Il s'est peut-être inspiré d'autres fables
célèbres, comme le Roman d'Alexandre qui
était pas mal côté à l'époque.
En tout cas il nous parle donc aussi de créatures
étranges, comme la salamandre, ou les hommes
cynocéphales sur l'île Andaman.
Ses descriptions peuvent donc être largement
remises en cause, même lorsqu'il n'y a pas
d'intervention de créature fantastique.
Si on veut chercher des témoignages fidèles
des orientaux vus par les occidentaux, on
peut chercher chez d'autres voyageurs: le
franciscain Jean de Plan Carpin, par exemple,
rencontre le Grand Khan en 1246 et rédige
à partir de son voyage une Histoire des Mongols
dans laquelle il mélange des légendes mongoles
et une description anthropologique de ces
derniers.
La mission suivante est celle de Guillaume
de Rubrouck, qui est envoyé par Saint-Louis
pour rencontrer le Grand Khan en 1249.
Il rédige à son retour le Voyage dans l'Empire
mongol qui donne les informations les plus
précises de tous ceux que j'ai cités:
il y parle des coutumes, des fêtes religieuses
et de l'habitat des différents peuples qu'il
a croisés.
Au XIVe siècle, les relations entre la Chine
et le monde chrétien cessent.
Les deux causes principales sont l'épidémie
de peste qui frappe les deux continents dans
les années 1340, voir l'épisode 16 si vous
l'avez manqué, et l'affaiblissement du pouvoir
mongol.
Il faut ensuite attendre la fin du XVe siècle
pour que de nouveaux européens, surtout des
portugais, se rendent en Asie lors de grandes
expéditions maritimes.
Ils se rendent en Inde, en Chine, au Japon,
et permettent d'améliorer les connaissances
géographiques de l'Asie qui n'avaient pas
beaucoup évolué depuis le livre des Merveilles
de Marco Polo.
Qui n'était déjà, pour un géographe puriste,
pas très folichon.
Genre y'avait des montagnes qui volaient,
façon Avatar.
-Non mais les hommes à tête de chien je
veux bien, mais des montagnes qui volent?
Sérieusement? Tu veux que je te dise ce
que c'est, son livre?
C'est des foutaises, le mec a dû arriver
chez le khan et découvrir les joies de la
drogue dès le premier mois pour avoir des
souvenirs pareils.
-Il a enjolivé un peu, c'est ça aussi qui
fait que sa vie est restée super connue alors
qu'elle n'était pas si exceptionnelle...
-Non, mais c'est plus qu'enjolivé là.
Balance les images, je vais te la raconter
sa vie «des merveilles».
L'histoire commence bien par Marco et sa famille
qui quittent leur ville pour aller explorer
le monde.
Arrivés aux pieds du Khan après une longue
chevauchée, ils lui offrent le Code du Travail,
un livre qui pèse plus de deux kilos, mais
le khan est pas content du tout parce qu'il
voulait cent savants, et parce qu'il ose pas
leur dire qu'il sait pas lire en fait.
En plus le mec est super riche, alors s'il
avait voulu un livre il aurait pu l'acheter
tout seul et le faire livrer plus vite, merci.
Du coup il envoie Marco parcourir le monde,
pour avoir la paix.
Pendant le voyage, Marco décide de prendre
son pied quitte à en perdre la tête.
Il fait pas les choses à moitié, il se fait
transporter à dos d'éléphacochères, la
grande classe.
A un moment il essaie de monter une troupe
de théâtre contemporain, mais le Khan trouve
ça trop avant-gardiste et lui coupe les subventions.
(illu découpage homme)
Alors il se lance dans le concours de caniche
LOOF, puis de dragons, il se cherche un peu.
Finalement, décidément passionné par les
animaux, il se lance dans la chasse à la
licorne.
Mais un jour ça tourne mal, une licorne lui
fait un tête à queue, et il décide de prendre
le large.
Il part vers de nouvelles îles et manque
de se faire embarquer par des hommes-sirènes,
mais les repousse en leur disait que c'est
pas l'homme qui prend la mer, c'est la mer
qui prend l'homme.
Là il arrive à Andaman où vivent des hommes
à tête de chien, qui l'accueillent plutôt
bien puis sortent leurs habits du dimanche
quand ils apprennent que c'est MARCO POLO.
Et puis c'est la partie dont il aime pas trop
parler, plein de gens à poil, on sait pas
trop ce qu'il s'est passé.
Finalement il donne des consignes de vote
à des gens qui sont incapables de prendre
des décisions par eux-même, et il rentre
chez lui après un petit jacuzzi.
Et c'est ça
l'histoire
de Marco Polo.